تنطلق صفارات الإنذار ، لقد وصلنا للتو
إلى محطة الطاقة ، كل
شخص دخل إلى المخبأ الذي سنضطر إلى الذهاب إليه
، ولا توجد ضجة ، يعلم الجميع هنا ما
يجب فعله ،
لقد اتفقنا على عدم إظهار الوجوه أو
تسمية القوة  لأسباب أمنية ،
لقد حصلنا على سترات الأمان هذه إلى
حيث يخبرنا المسؤولون هنا أنه من
الطبيعي جدًا أن ينتهي بهم المطاف في
القبو
عدة مرات في اليوم ، حيث ضربت محطة الطاقة التي تعمل بالفحم
مرتين منذ أن بدأ بوتين في
استهداف المنشآت الكهربائية لمدة 17 يومًا
قبل
بطاقات الدومينو التي تراسل الأحباء
يمر الوقت ،
لكن بما أن هذا المحارب المخضرم البالغ من العمر 29 عامًا في
مصنع الحقبة السوفيتية يخبرني أن كل دقيقة
في القبو يضيع الوقت ، يجب
أن يكونوا في القمة لإصلاح أضرار القنبلة بعد
ساعة ونصف ، كل شيء واضح
للجميع  العودة إلى العمل ، أحد أول
الأشياء التي تلاحظها هنا هو مدى الهدوء
الذي لا يوجد فيه مولدات تتقلب بعيدًا
حول الزاوية.
تمزق الصواريخ والطائرات بدون طيار
الجزء الأصعب من المصنع لإصلاح
الطائرة بدون طيار التي يقولون إنها متشابكة في
كابلات الجهد العالي هنا مما أدى إلى
تمزيق المعدات على الأرض هنا في
جميع
أنحاء الكابلات المحترقة وهنا المعدات المحترقة
والمسؤولون عن المشكلة  القول هو أن هذا
الجزء من الموقع كان الجزء الأكثر حساسية
لأنه كان غير متصل بالإنترنت منذ أن
أقنع المسؤولون هنا أن مهندسي الطاقة في بوتين
ينصحون
جيشه بتعطل شبكة الكهرباء الأوكرانية بالتأكيد أنهم
يعرفون المكان الضعيف وفي الواقع قاموا
بضربه ثلاث مرات في نفس الوقت
بالنسبة إلى المدة التي ستستغرقها الإصلاحات ، فلا أحد
يعرف أن المعدات فريدة تمامًا
لإنتاج بعضها الذي نحتاجه من 8
إلى 18 شهرًا وفي الواقع لن
يكون هناك الكثير من
الوقت على الرغم من بعض الإصلاحات السريعة
وفضل بوتين أكثر من 40
في المائة من الشبكة التي تم سحبها من الخط في
أقل من ثلاثة أسابيع ، هذا هو المكان الذي
أصاب فيه صاروخ كروز طائرتين بدون طيار
سقطت هناك ، حيث تم إخراج الأبراج هنا
لقد تم إصلاحها بالفعل
ولكن هذا هو الاختبار الكبير في الوقت الحالي ، هل يمكن
لأوكرانيا إصلاحها بشكل أسرع مما يمكن لروسيا أن
تقصف وتدمير
نيك روبرتسون CNN ومحطة طاقة في
أوكرانيا